hey guys it is Friday and apart from
that phrase conjuring up the horrible
image of that rebeccablack song it's
also the day where I scoured the last
seven days of news to bring you my five
favorite stories here they are
the first thing worth knowing about
today is that the Xbox one is getting
external storage support it's also
giving you the option to use your full
name but for some reason you guys were
less hyped about that what you are hyped
about is Microsoft continuing to listen
to what consumers want this newest move
involves the support of up to two
external hard drives which your xbox
will format for you they must be at
least 256 gigabytes and use USB 3 but if
you've got that covered
you can copy over your games and apps as
you please pretty cool
valve was officially launched it's
in-home streaming to steam out of beta 2
it's 75 million users basically that
means that now you can stream games from
your main PC to any other setup in your
home
meaning lower spec rigs are now totally
viable gaming options since they aren't
actually running on that system the
feature works between Windows Mac Linux
and steamos
although the host computer does
presently need to be a Windows machine
Ubisoft got themselves into a bit of hot
water this week as several people came
out to suggest that Park rifles cover
art is a little bit racist
the art looks like a white man with his
hand on the head of a darker skinned man
which has sparked a fair bit of
controversy but Yuri sought to come out
to say that that's not it at all
creative director Alex Hutchinson has
said he's not white and that's not the
player in response to an article on the
boxart let me know if you think this is
nonsense
or if you agree that the art isn't cool
rumors are suggesting that HD editions
of Halo 1 through 4 may be in the works
for the Xbox one in a mustard cheap
Edition Engadget is reporting that the
collection is intended to refresh
audiences memories before halo 5 lands
there's no word on who the developer
might be or any other details at all
actually but it's worth noting that 343
industries were helped out by Sabre
interactive on the tooth
and 11 anniversary edition of the
original hailer
lastly Microsoft have confirmed that
halo 5 guardians weren't becoming until
2015 but cryptically that the halo
journey will continue this year 343
industries general manager Bonnie Ross
said that they're making the game to run
at 60 frames per second with dedicated
servers and that it's a much bigger
effort than Halo 4 process said that the
title will incorporate what they've
learned from the previous installment in
terms of Technology aesthetics
performance and scale let me know
whether your hearts for this one or
whether you reckon halos had its day
this week on site be sure to check out
what's so damn good about Wolfenstein in
my latest episode of the gist cam tells
you how to go about that space journey
you've always wanted and Danny talks the
faith of the Kinect upon the point those
are all the things that I wanted to tell
you about today but thank you for tuning
in as always and I hope you have
yourself a lovely weekend